here's a piping hot tip of fresh out of
the oven
hey everybody i'm molly yay and i'm
going to show you how to make
homemade sprinkles you start with a big
bowl of powdered sugar
and i'm adding a little cayenne pepper
into mine because the combination of
chocolate and cayenne pepper
is delicious the liquid that's gonna
bring this all together is an egg white
i'm gonna add a little pinch of salt
just to bring out the flavor
i'm gonna add a little more food
coloring to bump up that reddish pinkish
color
i'm going to stand up my piping bag in
the cup and then i'll pour my mixture
right in
and i'm just going to pipe skinny little
lines like this
and then you leave them to dry overnight
uncovered and what you get are these
really long skinny sprinkles like that
and you just break them up and i'm going
to sprinkle these onto my brownies
just like that so i hope you guys have
fun making your own sprinkles
happy sprinkling if you're a renter this
is a great diy to get amazing backsplash
in your kitchen
i found these adhesive wall tiles by tic
tac tiles on amazon for less than thirty
dollars a pack
each pack comes with ten sheets and each
sheet is a twelve by twelve
all you need for this project is a razer
and exacto knife and tsp to clean the
walls
this is what the tiles look like up
close you can see that they're a little
bit more reflective than traditional
backsplash but they're also
super easy to remove all you need to do
is hold a blow dryer or heat gun over
them
wait for them to heat up and then they
peel right off with the amount of space
we wanted to cover we used about four
packs so in total this cost us around
120 dollars
i'm pretty sure that everyone has had
this type of limp before maybe because
it was in your college dorm or maybe
just because it's super inexpensive but
it comes in all sorts of colors and my
parents have a lot of them so today
i'm going to show you guys how to
upgrade it on a budget first you just
want to take off the shade
on the top and then you're going to want
to get some long three-quarter inch
dowels you can get these at the craft
store or lowe's is where i got them
and then all you have to do is glue them
on so i twisted them and glued them on
with some e6000 but you could use
gorilla glue or whatever you have laying
around
just make sure to let it dry overnight
and then we spray painted it gold in the
morning
and if you're not a fan of gold you
could choose any color spray paint that
you want
and then you'll just need a lampshade in
any style that you want i recommend
thrifting because it's a lot cheaper
you may need a harp depending on the
shade that you get but your lamp will go
from drab to fab
real fast this cost me a little under 30
dollars but most of the cost was the
shade so if you thrifted one
or just use an edison bulb instead it
would probably cost you around 15
and lamps like this are so expensive hi
drew it's board certified
dermatologist dr dendy engelmann here
today and i want to clear up
some of the myths about using oils on
the skin some of the reasons that oils
are great for the skin are that
they contain essential fatty acids which
are kind of the building blocks of skin
that our body doesn't produce naturally
so we really need them to help hydrate
so my first favorite oil is actually
argan oil and this is pure
organic argan oil from morocco and
contains tons of antioxidants that are
really good for protecting the skin
and healing it if you're oily or acne
prone next for those who have drier skin
or more mature skin
olive oil is what i want you to reach
for olives and olive oil are naturally
packed with antioxidants which prevents
free radical damage that we get from sun
and the environment like pollution those
over time can degrade or break down
collagen and elastin making our skin
look older and drier
and last is coconut oil look at this at
room temperature
it's solid so we don't want to put it
all over our face because it actually
could lead to breakouts
but it's awesome for hair thanks so much
drew
i hope that helps clear things up
here's the detailed diy of how i made my
headboard
i upcycled my old headboard but all you
need is a giant piece of plywood cut to
the size of your bed
for queen it is 60 inches by 30 inches
then all you're gonna need is some foam
i bought a twin foam mattress and cut it
to size
then i got two yards of fabric and two
yards of batting
then you're gonna lay your fabric
batting foam in wood down like a little
sandwich
pull your batting and your fabric taut
and then you just start stapling
i would do the batting all the way
around followed by the fabric
make sure your corners are crisp
and then you're happy because you're
literally done that's it
and now you have your favorite piece of
furniture
hi drew and hello everyone my name
is rebecca and i'm the owner of organize
for love
today i'm going to be providing some hot
tips for spring cleaning
all right so the first is you want to
gather old bath towels
old sheets and rags and you can donate
them to your animal shelter
a lot of people don't know is that
animal shelters are always in use of
those
items the second tip is you want to
take old pots and pans a lot of us
really use the same two or three pots
and so what you can do with old pots and
pans you can donate them to your local
scrap yard
and most scrap yards will give you money
for your old pots
i actually recently did this and i got a
whopping
three dollars okay and the last
tip is you want to take your
old suitcases and you want to donate
them to your local foster care
foster kids are typically forced to
move from place to place with their
items being a trash bag so this way they
can move
their things with dignity all right so
those are your three
hot tips for spring cleaning and i hope
these
help you make your space feel more
expensive
clutter free and peaceful hi drew
this is dr yael hales and my hot tip is
actually
facial yoga by exercising our facial
muscles
we can restore some of the facial volume
which we lose as we age
let's go through some of these simple
exercises to look
and namaste younger so the first one
actually is going to address the hollows
that we all develop around the eyes
we're going to make a lopsided smile
and we're going to keep this lopsided
smile the entire time
we're going to take our finger i'm going
to put it right here on this hollow
where we're going to be correcting this
muscle right here i'm gonna lean in so
you can see
now we're going to use this muscle right
here to kind of close
that eye do you see me doing that
that's the exercise the other thing that
we're going to be doing
is to smooth out what we call orange
peel skin
which is what happens right here when we
start getting dimpling of the chin
what we can do is we just pull our skin
forward like
the we just feel that muscle move
forward
women who complied with this exercise
regime of facial yoga
daily for several months actually were
able to take three years off
of their facial appearance i can't wait
to try that
[Music]